bentornato a Capire l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico, mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico dell'educazione presso IBM
Quantum. Questa è la decima lezione della serie ed è la seconda lezione della terza unità, che tratta la formulazione generale
dell'informazione quantistica. Questa lezione riguarda i canali, che rappresentano i cambiamenti nei
sistemi che memorizzano informazioni quantistiche. Questo include operazioni utili come quelle eseguite da
gate unitari e circuit quantistici, nonché cambiamenti che potremmo preferire evitare, come il rumore. Possiamo anche descrivere le misurazioni
come canali, e questo è qualcosa che affronteremo nella prossima lezione. Il termine canale ci viene dalla
teoria dell'informazione, che tra le altre cose studia la capacità di trasporto dell'informazione dei canali di comunicazione
rumorosi. Quindi quando pensiamo ai canali stiamo pensando astrattamente ai canali di comunicazione.
Potrebbe sembrare un po' strano pensare a un calcolo complicato come a un canale di comunicazione, ma abbiamo bisogno di una
parola per riferirci alla nozione generale di un processo che cambia l'informazione in qualche modo. E, nel bene o nel male, la parola
canale si è affermata, senza dubbio in gran parte a causa dell'enorme impatto che la teoria dell'informazione e in particolare il
lavoro di Claude Shannon negli anni '40 ha avuto sull'informazione e il calcolo quantistico. Ecco una panoramica della
lezione: inizieremo con le basi, inclusa la definizione di cos'è un canale, nonché come le operazioni unitarie nella formulazione semplificata
dell'informazione quantistica possono essere descritte come canali. Parleremo anche del fatto che le combinazioni convesse di canali sono canali, e se ti stai
chiedendo perché questa nozione di convessità continua a comparire, è perché è davvero una nozione matematica fondamentalmente importante nella teoria dell'
informazione quantistica. Vedremo anche alcuni esempi di canali, in particolare canali di qubit, che ricompariranno di tanto in
tanto per il resto della lezione. Nella seconda parte della lezione parleremo di tre modi diversi in cui possiamo rappresentare i canali
matematicamente, e in particolare parleremo delle rappresentazioni di Stinespring, delle rappresentazioni di Kraus e delle rappresentazioni di Choi,
che prendono il nome da tre persone il cui lavoro è stato importante nello sviluppo di queste diverse rappresentazioni. E nella terza e
ultima parte della lezione discuteremo una dimostrazione matematica che stabilisce che queste tre rappresentazioni sono di fatto equivalenti, nonché il fatto che
tutte caratterizzano correttamente la definizione di cos'è un canale. È una dimostrazione matematica davvero elegante secondo me, e speriamo che aggiunga un po' di
chiarezza a queste diverse rappresentazioni: come si relazionano e come funzionano in generale. Iniziamo con le basi e
affrontiamo la domanda: cosa sono i canali? Come ho già suggerito all'inizio della lezione, i canali descrivono i cambiamenti:
più specificamente, i cambiamenti a tempo discreto nei sistemi che memorizzano informazioni quantistiche. Quando ci riferiamo a un cambiamento a tempo
discreto, stiamo solo pensando a un cambiamento che avviene tra due momenti distinti nel tempo, al contrario di un
processo continuo, ad esempio, che ha senso pensare su periodi di tempo infinitamente piccoli. I canali includono operazioni utili come
le operazioni unitarie eseguite da gate e circuit quantistici, nonché i cambiamenti dovuti al rumore. Ad esempio, per
gli scopi di questa lezione, penseremo principalmente ai canali in termini matematici astratti, e non ci sarà alcun particolare bisogno
di distinguere tra ciò che è utile e ciò che non lo è. I nomi tipici per i canali includono le lettere greche maiuscole Φ
(Phi), Ψ (Psi) e Ω (Omega), e useremo lettere diverse per riferirci ad alcuni canali specifici. In una situazione semplice in cui
abbiamo un sistema in uno stato descritto da una certa matrice densità ρ e applichiamo un canale Φ a quel sistema, il
risultato è un sistema il cui stato è descritto dalla matrice densità Φ(ρ). Quindi stiamo pensando a un dato
canale Φ come una funzione che può essere applicata alle matrici densità di una particolare dimensione, ovvero alle matrici densità
di un particolare sistema a cui stiamo applicando questo canale. Ci sono un paio di requisiti che i canali devono soddisfare per essere
considerati canali validi. Primo, i canali sono mappature lineari. Questo è completamente analogo alla situazione che abbiamo sia
nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica, in cui le operazioni sui vettori di stato quantistico sono necessariamente lineari, sia
nella formulazione standard dell'informazione classica, in cui le operazioni probabilistiche sono lineari. Potresti scegliere di mettere in discussione questo requisito di base
della linearità se volessi davvero, ma se vogliamo una teoria coerente sia con la teoria della probabilità
che con la scelta di rappresentare gli stati quantistici con matrici densità, allora non abbiamo davvero scelta e dobbiamo accettare che i canali siano lineari.
Il secondo requisito è che i canali trasformino le matrici densità in matrici densità. Ha perfettamente senso: se abbiamo scelto di rappresentare
gli stati dei sistemi con matrici densità e applichiamo un canale a un sistema in qualche stato, il risultato deve essere uno stato valido e quindi
rappresentato da una matrice densità. C'è però un punto molto importante da aggiungere, ovvero che questo requisito
deve essere vero non solo se applichiamo un canale a un sistema isolato il cui stato è descritto da una matrice densità,
ma anche se abbiamo un sistema composto il cui stato è descritto da una certa matrice densità e applichiamo il canale a solo
una parte di quel sistema. Questi sono quindi i requisiti che poniamo sui canali, e possiamo vedere che sono molto
analoghi ai requisiti che abbiamo per le operazioni sia nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica sia nella formulazione standard
dell'informazione classica. Nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica, le operazioni sono rappresentate da matrici unitarie perché corrispondono
precisamente alle mappe lineari che trasformano sempre i vettori di stato quantistici in vettori di stato quantistici per un
dato sistema. Allo stesso modo, le operazioni probabilistiche sono rappresentate da matrici stocastiche perché quelle sono le matrici che
trasformano sempre i vettori di probabilità in vettori di probabilità. Qui stiamo lavorando con matrici densità e c'è
questo requisito aggiunto riguardante i sistemi composti, che risulta non essere necessario per i vettori di stato quantistici
o i vettori di probabilità. Ma altrimenti i requisiti sono analoghi e in un certo senso ci vengono imposti dalla scelta
di rappresentare gli stati quantistici con matrici densità. Ecco alcuni ulteriori dettagli sui canali, inclusa una convenzione
su come penseremo ai sistemi di input e output di un canale per tutta la lezione, nonché qualche dettaglio in più
sul requisito che i canali trasformino sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità. Prima di tutto, si assume che ogni canale abbia
un sistema di input e un sistema di output. Possiamo nominare questi sistemi come vogliamo, ma per tutta questa
lezione userò il nome X per riferirmi al sistema di input e il nome Y per riferirmi al sistema di output. Concettualmente, il canale
trasforma il sistema di input nel sistema di output, quindi i sistemi di input e output non coesistono mai simultaneamente: iniziamo
con X, il canale viene applicato o eseguito, e il risultato è che X è stato trasformato in Y, il cui stato è
determinato dalla mappatura lineare associata al canale. I sistemi di input e output per un canale non devono essere gli stessi, e in particolare
non devono avere lo stesso numero di stati classici. Tuttavia, può essere che i sistemi di input e output siano in realtà lo stesso sistema, ovvero
X uguale a Y, nel qual caso stiamo semplicemente immaginando che Φ stia cambiando lo stato del sistema. E in effetti questa è
molto spesso la situazione che ci interessa, ma questa possibilità è coerente con il primo punto nel senso che non abbiamo mai i
sistemi di input e output che esistono come due sistemi separati allo stesso tempo. In ogni caso, sarà conveniente per
gli scopi di questa lezione usare lettere diverse, cioè X e Y, per riferirci ai sistemi di input e output
per aiutarci a tenere le cose ordinate. Entriamo ora in qualche dettaglio in più sul requisito che i canali trasformino sempre le matrici
densità in matrici densità. Supponiamo di introdurre un nuovo sistema Z nella situazione. Diamo
il nome Γ all'insieme degli stati classici di questo nuovo sistema. Immaginiamo ora di formare un nuovo sistema composto ZX
composto dal nuovo sistema insieme al sistema di input X di un canale Φ, e supponiamo che questo sistema composto si trovi
in uno stato descritto da una matrice densità ρ. Questo può essere uno stato quantistico arbitrario di questa coppia, ma qualunque stato sia,
è sempre possibile esprimere la matrice densità ρ nella forma mostrata sullo schermo, dove sia A che B
variano sull'insieme degli stati classici Γ, e ogni ρ_ è una matrice le cui righe e colonne corrispondono a qualunque cosa
sia l'insieme degli stati classici di X. Non dobbiamo dare un nome a quell'insieme degli stati classici in questo momento. Solo per chiarire: ogni ρ_ non è necessariamente una
matrice densità da sola, ma l'intera matrice ρ è necessariamente una matrice densità. Quando applichiamo il canale Φ al
sistema X, viene trasformato in Y, e quindi rimaniamo con la coppia ZY. Il modo in cui determiniamo lo
stato di questa coppia dopo aver eseguito Φ su solo X è valutare la mappatura lineare Φ su ciascuna delle matrici ρ_.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che prendiamo il prodotto tensoriale della mappatura Φ con la mappatura identità sulle matrici quadrate con righe e colonne
corrispondenti a Γ, e ciò a sua volta corrisponde a non fare nulla a questo nuovo sistema Z. Ma questa è una descrizione equivalente
e non richiede entrare nei dettagli sui prodotti tensoriali di mappature di questa forma. Esse
funzionano però in modo abbastanza semplice, analogo a come funzionano per vettori e matrici. Un modo per pensarci visivamente è
in termini di matrici a blocchi. E se facciamo l'ipotesi semplificatrice che l'insieme degli stati classici Γ consista degli
interi tra 0 e M-1 per qualche intero positivo M, diventa facile scrivere tutto questo come
mostrato qui. E ora, per ripetere il requisito che stiamo ponendo su Φ affinché sia un canale valido: dobbiamo sempre ottenere una matrice
densità da questo processo, e questo deve essere vero indipendentemente dalla scelta che facciamo per il sistema Z e dalla
scelta che facciamo per ρ, purché sia una matrice densità. Potrebbe sembrare un requisito piuttosto severo e
potrebbe anche sembrare molto difficile da verificare. Ma come vedremo entro la fine della lezione, in realtà non è così severo
o difficile da verificare. In particolare, abbiamo buone caratterizzazioni matematiche per questa condizione
che sono collegate alle diverse rappresentazioni di cui parleremo più avanti nella lezione. Vediamo ora alcuni esempi di canali,
iniziando con un'intera categoria di canali chiamati canali unitari. In termini semplici, questi sono le operazioni unitarie
proprio come le abbiamo nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica, viste come canali. Per essere precisi, supponiamo che U sia una matrice unitaria
che rappresenta un'operazione unitaria su un sistema X. Quindi nella formulazione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica
moltiplicheremmo questa matrice a un dato vettore di stato quantistico per determinare l'azione che quell'operazione ha su quel vettore di stato quantistico. Il
modo in cui questo funziona per le matrici densità è che moltiplichiamo la matrice densità a sinistra per U e a destra per U
dagger. In termini matematici, questa operazione viene chiamata coniugazione per la matrice U. Questo è coerente con
|ψ⟩⟨ψ| che è la matrice densità che descrive lo stato rappresentato dal vettore di stato quantistico ψ, ed è abbastanza
facile verificare che in particolare se eseguissimo U sul vettore di stato quantistico |ψ⟩ otterremmo U * |ψ⟩, e la sua
rappresentazione come matrice densità è data da quel vettore moltiplicato per il suo trasposto coniugato, che è U * |ψ⟩ * ⟨ψ| * U
dagger. Il modo in cui questo canale è definito ha quindi senso per gli stati puri, e quando combiniamo questo con la linearità vediamo che ha senso per le matrici densità in
generale, grazie al fatto che ogni matrice densità può essere espressa come combinazione convessa di stati puri. Questa
definizione ci dà sempre un canale valido per qualsiasi scelta di un'operazione unitaria U. In particolare, coniugare per
una matrice unitaria come questa non cambia la traccia di una matrice, e se coniughiamo qualsiasi matrice semidefinita positiva
per qualsiasi matrice otterremo un'altra matrice semidefinita positiva. È abbastanza facile ottenerlo
direttamente dalla definizione di matrici semidefinite positive. Quindi le matrici densità vengono sempre mappate in matrici densità,
e tutto questo rimane vero anche se tensorizziamo U con la matrice identità di qualsiasi dimensione, il che equivale
ad applicare questo canale a solo una parte di un sistema composto. Ecco un esempio davvero semplice di canale unitario: supponiamo che
U stesso sia la matrice identità. Questo è ovviamente un canale valido chiamato il canale identità. Non fare
assolutamente nulla è certamente un'operazione lineare, e se iniziamo con una matrice densità e non facciamo nulla, sarà ancora
una matrice densità. Quindi questo è un canale valido. Le persone usano simboli diversi per denotare questo canale:
a volte è esattamente lo stesso simbolo che usiamo per la matrice identità, il che può essere un po' confuso, ma in genere non lo è. Qui sto usando
le lettere ID, abbreviazione di identità, solo per evitare confusione, e anche questa notazione è abbastanza comune. Potrebbe sembrare un
canale molto noioso, ma nel contesto della trasmissione dell'informazione è in realtà un canale perfetto in cui
il ricevitore ottiene esattamente ciò che il mittente invia, che è tipicamente ciò che si vuole nella maggior parte dei casi. Un altro modo in cui possiamo
ottenere molti esempi di canali è prendere le combinazioni convesse di canali, ovvero calcolare la loro media,
e il fatto che possiamo farlo è un aspetto importante dei canali. Per spiegarlo in maggiore dettaglio, iniziamo con due canali Φ₀ e Φ₁ diciamo,
insieme a un numero reale p tra 0 e 1. Solo per chiarire, stiamo assumendo che questi due canali abbiano lo stesso sistema di input,
che è X, nonché lo stesso sistema di output, che è Y. Consideriamo ora cosa succede se decidiamo di
applicare il primo canale Φ₀ con probabilità p e altrimenti con la rimanente probabilità 1-p applichiamo
il secondo canale Φ₁. Ad esempio, forse scegliamo casualmente un bit con quelle probabilità e poi usiamo questo bit casuale
per determinare quale canale applicare. Facendo questo, stiamo effettivamente applicando un nuovo canale che potremmo chiamare Ψ,
dato da una combinazione convessa dei due canali con cui abbiamo iniziato, e che possiamo esprimere come scritto
sullo schermo. Possiamo sempre prendere combinazioni lineari di mappe lineari in questo modo, tra l'altro, e il modo in cui una combinazione lineare
di mappe lineari è definita su un dato input è che prendiamo semplicemente la stessa combinazione lineare degli output.
Una combinazione lineare di mappe lineari è definita su un dato input semplicemente prendendo la stessa combinazione lineare degli output.
Potrebbe sembrare banale, ma ha senso: l'output che otteniamo da questo scenario ipotetico è semplicemente la
media pesata degli output che otterremmo dai due canali originali. Tuttavia, questo è un nuovo canale, e
se Φ₀ e Φ₁ erano canali validi allora sicuramente anche questa nuova mappatura sarà un canale valido. Un altro modo per dirlo
in termini matematici è che l'insieme di tutti i canali da un dato sistema di input a un dato sistema di output è
convesso, e questa è un'importante proprietà matematica dei canali. Possiamo fare questo più in generale: se abbiamo M canali Φ₀ fino a Φ_ diciamo,
insieme a un vettore di probabilità che ci dice qual è la probabilità di ciascun canale, otteniamo un nuovo canale mediando i canali di conseguenza.
Quindi in un certo senso questa è una fonte infinita di nuovi canali. Ad esempio, la classe dei cosiddetti canali unitari misti è ciò che
otteniamo prendendo le combinazioni convesse dei canali unitari. Ovvero, se abbiamo M matrici unitarie U₀ fino a U_
tutte della stessa dimensione, insieme al vettore di probabilità, se prendiamo la media pesata dei canali
corrispondenti alle singole matrici unitarie come mostrato qui sullo schermo, otterremo un canale. E i canali
che possono essere scritti così si chiamano canali unitari misti. Non ogni canale è un canale unitario misto: non possiamo ottenere
ogni canale in questo modo, ma compaiono abbastanza spesso. Vediamo ora alcuni esempi specifici
di canali. Questi saranno tutti esempi di canali da un qubit a un qubit, chiamati canali di qubit
per brevità. Il primo si chiama canale di reset del qubit, e l'idea è che questo canale reimposta un qubit
allo stato zero. Qui usiamo la lettera greca maiuscola Λ per denotare questo canale. Il modo per ricordare cosa fa questo canale è
pensare alla sfera di Bloch: la lettera maiuscola Λ assomiglia a una freccia che punta in su, e lo stato zero è in cima alla sfera di Bloch. È come se
stesse indicando la posizione dell'output. Il modo in cui è definito in termini matematici è che Λ(ρ) uguale alla traccia di ρ moltiplicato per |0⟩⟨0|. Quindi
se lo valutiamo su qualsiasi matrice densità ρ otterremo lo stato zero come matrice densità. È naturale chiedersi
perché abbiamo bisogno della traccia: non potremmo semplicemente definire Λ(ρ) come |0⟩⟨0| senza la traccia di ρ davanti?
E la risposta a questa domanda è no: i canali devono essere mappe lineari, e non sarebbe lineare se rimuovessimo la traccia di ρ. Tieni presente anche che
a volte abbiamo bisogno di sapere come funziona un canale come mappa lineare su input che non sono matrici densità. Ad esempio, come
abbiamo visto prima, se vogliamo sapere cosa fa un canale quando lo applichiamo a un sistema composto dobbiamo
valutare quel canale sui singoli blocchi di una matrice a blocchi più grande. E anche se l'intera matrice a blocchi può essere
una matrice densità, i singoli blocchi in genere non lo saranno. Vediamo quindi esattamente cosa fa questo canale quando lo applichiamo
a solo una parte di un sistema composto, e più specificamente cosa fa quando lo applichiamo a uno dei due qubit che
formano un ebit. Per essere precisi, supponiamo che A e B siano qubit che come coppia si trovano nello stato di Bell Φ+ e applichiamo Λ
diciamo al primo qubit A. Per capire cosa succede, esprimiamo prima lo stato Φ+ come matrice densità. E
ai fini di questo esempio usiamo la notazione di Dirac per farlo. Ecco lo stato Φ+ come vettore di stato quantistico, ed ecco ciò che otteniamo quando
moltiplichiamo questo vettore per il suo trasposto coniugato e lo espandiamo tutto. Poi possiamo applicare il canale al primo qubit e valutare ciò che otteniamo. Ecco
Λ applicato al primo qubit, ed ecco ciò che otteniamo quando valutiamo ciascuno dei termini: la traccia di |0⟩⟨0| è uno,
e così è la traccia di |1⟩⟨1|, quindi in quei due casi l'output del canale è |0⟩⟨0|, e questo spiega
i due termini nella risposta. La traccia di |0⟩⟨1| d'altra parte è zero, così come la traccia di |1⟩⟨0|,
e quindi quei due termini si valutano a zero e quindi non contribuiscono nulla alla risposta. Ora possiamo semplificare un
po' e ciò che otteniamo è lo stato zero per il primo qubit A e lo stato completamente misto per il
secondo qubit B. Nota in particolare che non abbiamo ottenuto uno stato più per B, il che non sarebbe stata necessariamente una cattiva ipotesi se non sapessimo nulla delle matrici densità
e guardassimo solo la rappresentazione come vettore di stato quantistico dello stato. Ma non è così che funziona questo canale, e non c'è nessun canale che potrebbe funzionare in quel modo.
Il canale Λ è chiamato canale di reset del qubit, ma il modo in cui funziona è più come buttare il qubit di input nella spazzatura e sostituirlo con un qubit fresco nello stato zero. Ma questo è in effetti l'unico
canale di qubit che restituisce sempre lo stato zero. Ecco un altro esempio di canale di qubit, noto come il
canale di defasing completo. Questo è denotato da Δ, e il modo in cui funziona è che lascia le voci diagonali
di qualsiasi matrice 2x2 invariate e azzera le voci fuori dalla diagonale. Δ è la lettera greca equivalente di D nell'
alfabeto latino, e D sta per diagonale. Questo è un modo per ricordare cosa fa questo canale. Possiamo in alternativa esprimere
questo canale usando la notazione di Dirac come mostrato sullo schermo. Solo per chiarire, l'output è sempre una matrice 2x2, quindi
in particolare i due output zero si riferiscono alla matrice 2x2 tutta zero. Facciamo spesso questo, e l'abbiamo visto prima in questa serie:
il simbolo zero è generalmente usato, forse ambiguamente, per indicare l'elemento zero di qualunque cosa si stia parlando, che siano scalari, vettori, matrici o
qualsiasi altra cosa. Facciamo la stessa cosa che abbiamo fatto prima per il canale di reset del qubit e vediamo cosa succede se applichiamo questo canale a metà di un ebit. La configurazione è la stessa quindi non
rielaborerò quella parte. E il risultato è lo stato mostrato sullo schermo, che è essenzialmente un bit casuale condiviso. Quindi quello che
ha fatto questo canale è fondamentalmente convertire un ebit in una coppia di bit casuali classici perfettamente correlati.
E questo è coerente con un'interpretazione più generale di questo canale: azzerando le voci fuori dalla diagonale di una matrice densità, stiamo effettivamente
eliminando la parte quantistica da una matrice densità, lasciando una matrice densità diagonale che rappresenta uno stato
probabilistico classico. Un altro modo per pensarci è che questo canale rappresenta un canale classico perfetto e senza rumore che trasmette un bit:
se inseriamo nel canale uno stato zero o uno stato uno, o una combinazione convessa di quei due stati, quello stato esce invariato. Ma se provi a
inserirci uno stato quantistico, come uno stato più ad esempio, è come se il canale misurasse quello stato con una misurazione nella base standard e poi
trasmettesse il risultato classico. Un ultimo esempio di canale di qubit è il canale completamente depolarizzante. Quello che
fa questo canale è sempre restituire lo stato completamente misto, quindi è simile in qualche senso al canale di reset del
qubit, tranne che otteniamo uno stato completamente misto piuttosto meno utile invece di un qubit inizializzato. Un modo naturale
per pensare a questo canale è che rappresenta una forma estrema di rumore, e per quanto riguarda i canali di qubit
non può diventare più rumoroso di così. Non ho un buon trucco mnemonico da condividere per ricordare cosa fa questo, se non dire che Ω è l'ultima
lettera dell'alfabeto greco e a volte è associata alla fine di tutte le cose. Forse è questo che succede
a tutti i qubit alla fine. Per quanto riguarda il rumore è abbastanza estremo, ma una cosa che possiamo fare è considerare una combinazione convessa
di questo canale e del canale identità, con forse una piccola probabilità epsilon per la depolarizzazione completa.
Questa è una forma di rumore meno estrema, in cui un dato stato di qubit sarà per lo più lasciato invariato, ma c'è
una piccola probabilità che diventi completamente misto. Geometricamente possiamo pensare a questo come a una leggera contrazione della sfera di Bloch verso il centro.
E tra l'altro possiamo fare qualcosa di simile con il canale di defasing completo per modellare il processo di decoerenza ad esempio, in cui le cose
diventano leggermente più classiche attraverso qualche processo. Questi sono quindi tre esempi di base di canali di qubit, e torneremo su di essi
principalmente come fonte di esempi per il resto della lezione. Discutiamo poi le rappresentazioni matematiche
dei canali, iniziando con una domanda di base: le mappature lineari da vettori a vettori possono sempre essere
rappresentate da matrici in modo familiare, ovvero l'azione della mappatura lineare è descritta dalla moltiplicazione matrice-
vettore. Ma i canali sono mappature lineari da matrici a matrici, non da vettori a vettori. Quindi in
generale come possiamo esprimere i canali in termini matematici? A volte, per canali speciali, avremo una formula semplice
che li descrive, e questo era il caso negli esempi di canali di qubit che abbiamo già discusso. Ma questo non è
pratico in generale perché non ci sarà sempre una formula così elegante. Come punto di confronto, nella formulazione semplificata
dell'informazione quantistica usiamo matrici unitarie per rappresentare operazioni sui vettori di stato quantistici:
ogni matrice unitaria rappresenta un'operazione valida e ogni operazione valida può essere espressa come matrice unitaria. Quindi in
sostanza quello che questa domanda sta chiedendo è come facciamo questo per i canali, e la risposta a questa domanda è che ci sono
in effetti più modi per rappresentare i canali in termini matematici. In particolare, discuteremo tre modi diversi di rappresentare i canali
che prendono il nome da tre individui il cui lavoro ha svolto un ruolo importante nel loro sviluppo: Stinespring, Kraus e Choi.
Prima vedremo come funzionano queste diverse rappresentazioni, e poi nell'ultima parte della lezione vedremo come le tre rappresentazioni si relazionano e in
particolare come possiamo convertire tra di loro. Vedremo anche che queste rappresentazioni catturano precisamente i requisiti che abbiamo sui canali,
cioè che sono mappature lineari e che trasformano sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità anche quando
vengono applicate a solo una parte di un sistema composto. Prima le rappresentazioni di Stinespring. William Forrest Stinespring
era un matematico che non ha lavorato sull'informazione quantistica, e le rappresentazioni di Stinespring come le descriverò
sono in qualche senso solo una derivazione del suo lavoro sulla teoria degli operatori negli anni '50. Ma questo lavoro è stato certamente
una parte importante dello sviluppo della matematica su cui si basano i canali quantistici. L'idea dietro questo modo di rappresentare i canali è che ogni
canale può essere implementato in un certo modo che descrivo ora. Prima formiamo un sistema composto composto dall'
input del canale che stiamo implementando insieme a un sistema workspace inizializzato. Poi viene
eseguita un'operazione unitaria sul sistema composto. E infine, qualunque parte del sistema composto risultante
corrisponda all'output del canale viene lasciata intatta o restituita come output, e il resto viene scartato o tracciato fuori.
È utile esprimere tutto questo sotto forma di diagramma, ed è più semplice iniziare con il caso speciale in cui i sistemi di input e
output sono gli stessi. Questo diagramma, tra l'altro, è proprio come un diagramma di circuit quantistico, tranne che i fili
rappresentano sistemi arbitrari e non necessariamente singoli qubit. Quindi iniziamo con il sistema di input X in qualche
stato ρ. Introduciamo un sistema workspace inizializzato W, e in questo diagramma sto presumendo che 0 sia uno stato classico
di W e prendiamo |0⟩ come stato inizializzato del sistema. Ma potremmo alternativamente fissare qualsiasi stato puro
di W e vederlo come lo stato inizializzato. Poi eseguiamo qualche operazione unitaria sulla coppia WX, e poi
tracciamo il sistema workspace e restituiamo X. Qui nel diagramma, tra l'altro, sto usando il simbolo di massa di terra dall'
ingegneria elettrica per indicare che W viene scartato. Non è necessariamente convenzionale, e non troverai quel simbolo
in Qiskit: lì ignori semplicemente i qubit che non ti interessano. Il punto è che voglio solo avere un simbolo che renda
chiaro che stiamo scartando il sistema. Ai fini di questa discussione, in generale non abbiamo necessariamente bisogno che i sistemi di input e
output siano gli stessi, quindi possiamo avere ad esempio un sistema di output Y insieme a un sistema spazzatura G
che viene tracciato fuori. Affinché U sia unitario deve essere una matrice quadrata, quindi c'è l'ipotesi
che la coppia GY insieme abbia lo stesso numero di stati classici della coppia WX. Ad esempio, forse questi sistemi
sono qubit e il sistema di input X consiste di 5 qubit e W consiste di 10 qubit, quindi U è un'operazione unitaria
su 15 qubit. Potrebbe poi essere che Y consista di solo quattro qubit, il che significa che G consiste di 11 qubit.
O forse non si tratta di qubit: tutto ciò che è importante è che WX insieme e GY insieme abbiano lo stesso numero di
stati classici, affinché U possa essere unitario. Una descrizione di un canale come questa è chiamata rappresentazione di Stinespring del canale. È
abbastanza semplice argomentare che qualsiasi mappatura Φ che può essere descritta in questo modo è di fatto un canale valido.
In particolare, se iniziamo con una matrice densità e poi aggiungiamo un sistema workspace aggiuntivo, saremo certamente
lasciati con una matrice densità. Abbiamo già osservato che applicare un'operazione unitaria ci dà un canale valido. E
se abbiamo una matrice densità di un sistema composto e tracciamo fuori uno dei sistemi, di nuovo saremo lasciati con una matrice densità. Quindi quando componiamo
questi passi saremo garantiti che trasformi sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità, ed è anche lineare.
Ciò che non è affatto chiaro a questo punto è che ogni canale può effettivamente essere implementato in questo modo per qualche scelta
del sistema workspace e del sistema spazzatura, nonché dell'operazione unitaria U. Ma questo è vero, e
ne vedremo la ragione entro la fine della lezione. Ecco un esempio di rappresentazione di Stinespring per il canale di defasing completo del
qubit. Per chiarire, ora i fili sono qubit, e questo è un gate CNOT ordinario.
È molto semplice: il qubit di input è in cima, introduciamo un qubit workspace inizializzato allo stato zero,
poi eseguiamo un'operazione CNOT in cui il qubit di input è il controllo e il qubit workspace è il
target, e poi il qubit workspace viene tracciato fuori. Intuitivamente ha senso
che questo dovrebbe implementare il canale di defasing completo, perché il gate CNOT agisce un po' come una misurazione nella base standard sul qubit
in alto, copiando il suo stato classico sul qubit in basso, e poi il risultato viene buttato
via. Ma possiamo anche fare un calcolo, ed è ovviamente una buona idea farlo perché non dovremmo
fidarci troppo della nostra intuizione. Possiamo iniziare scrivendo la rappresentazione come matrice densità dei due
qubit dopo che il qubit workspace è stato introdotto. Nota che stiamo usando la convenzione di ordinamento dei qubit
come al solito, dove il qubit in basso è quello a sinistra e il qubit in alto è a destra. Possiamo esprimere questa matrice densità
esplicitamente come una matrice 4x4 effettiva come mostrato sullo schermo, e poi calcoliamo l'effetto
che il gate CNOT ha su questa matrice densità. Quindi coniughiamo per la matrice unitaria associata a questo
gate, tenendo ancora presente la convenzione di ordinamento dei qubit. Questa è quindi la matrice unitaria corretta,
e il risultato è mostrato qui. In effetti, il gate CNOT
ha permutato le voci della nostra matrice originale un po'. Quindi ora le voci potenzialmente non nulle si trovano nei quattro
angoli. Rimane calcolare la traccia parziale. Potremmo farlo direttamente dalla matrice, ma un'
alternativa è convertire alla notazione di Dirac come mostrato sullo schermo, e poi diventa abbastanza facile valutare
cosa succede quando tracciamo fuori il qubit a sinistra all'interno di ciascun termine. E il risultato è che sopravvivono solo i
termini corrispondenti alle voci diagonali di ρ, e quindi abbiamo defasato il qubit come
previsto. Come sempre, verifica questo per conto tuo al tuo ritmo se vuoi farlo. È un buon
esempio per fare pratica con le matrici densità e con le
tracce parziali. Questo non è l'unico modo per implementare il canale di defasing completo: ecco una rappresentazione di Stinespring alternativa per questo
canale. Non spiegherò il calcolo in dettaglio in questo video, ma lo mostrerò brevemente nel caso tu voglia fermare il video per dargli un'
occhiata più da vicino. Il modo in cui funziona è simile al primo, ma i dettagli sono
diversi. Questa volta iniziamo con un gate Hadamard sul qubit workspace, che lo mette in uno stato più. E se
espandiamo il prodotto tensoriale otteniamo la matrice mostrata sullo schermo. Per applicare il gate Z controllato
coniughiamo per la matrice unitaria associata, e il risultato di questo è iniettare alcuni segni meno nella
matrice. In particolare, l'ultima riga e l'ultima colonna vengono entrambe moltiplicate per -1.
E questa volta sarebbe abbastanza complicato convertire alla notazione di Dirac, quindi calcoleremo la traccia parziale
direttamente. Quando tracciamo fuori il primo dei due qubit, quello che otteniamo è la somma dei due blocchi 2x2 diagonali,
e quindi il risultato finale è di nuovo che abbiamo defasato il qubit. È stata rapida, e se non sei
abituato a questo tipo di calcoli, prenditi il tuo tempo e fallo lentamente: la velocità non è importante
qui. Per completare questo esempio, lasciami menzionare che c'è un'idea abbastanza semplice dietro questa implementazione, che è
abbastanza ben espressa dall'ultimo passo del calcolo che abbiamo appena brevemente scorso. Un modo più succinto per dirlo
è che se calcoliamo la media di una data matrice densità di qubit con quella matrice densità coniugata per la matrice Pauli Z, allora
è la stessa cosa del defasing. Quindi il canale di defasing completo risulta essere un canale unitario misto
in cui o non facciamo nulla, cioè eseguiamo l'operazione identità, o eseguiamo un gate Z, ciascuno
con probabilità 1/2. Bene a sapersi. Quindi in sintesi, abbiamo due diverse
rappresentazioni di Stinespring del canale di defasing completo, e questo ci dice qualcosa di importante, ovvero che le rappresentazioni di Stinespring
non sono uniche. E in effetti ce ne sono infinitamente molte per qualsiasi dato canale. Discutiamo poi le rappresentazioni di Kraus
dei canali, che ci danno un modo comodo e formulaico di esprimere i canali attraverso la moltiplicazione e l'addizione di matrici.
Le rappresentazioni di Kraus prendono il nome da Karl Kraus, un fisico che tra le altre cose ha elaborato
molti dei dettagli matematici di base dei canali e della formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica più ampiamente. In generale, una
rappresentazione di Kraus è un'espressione di un canale della forma mostrata qui sullo schermo. In particolare, abbiamo una
raccolta di matrici, qui chiamate A₀ fino a A_ per qualche intero positivo N, e specificano
l'azione del canale su qualsiasi dato input ρ secondo la formula. In breve, coniughiamo ρ per ciascuna di queste matrici,
spesso chiamate matrici di Kraus in questo contesto, e poi sommiamo il risultato, ottenendo l'output. Tutte queste matrici devono avere
le stesse dimensioni, e specificatamente le loro colonne devono corrispondere agli stati classici del sistema di input e
le righe devono corrispondere agli stati classici del sistema di output. In tal caso, quando prendiamo il prodotto A_K * ρ * A_K† per qualsiasi
scelta di K, otteniamo una matrice quadrata le cui righe e colonne corrispondono agli stati classici del sistema di output.
Quindi ha senso che l'espressione produca una matrice densità del sistema di output. Ora, non è il caso
che per una scelta arbitraria di queste matrici di Kraus si ottenga un canale valido. C'è però una condizione abbastanza semplice
sulle matrici che garantisce che otterremo un canale valido, ed è la formula mostrata qui.
Specificamente, se sommiamo il prodotto di A_K† * A_K su tutti i valori di K,
dobbiamo ottenere la matrice identità, e quella sarà la matrice identità le cui righe e colonne corrispondono agli stati classici
del sistema di input. Quindi quella condizione deve essere soddisfatta affinché la mappatura definita dalla
prima equazione sia un canale valido. E risulta che ogni canale ha in effetti una rappresentazione che ha
questa forma, purché prendiamo N abbastanza grande. Ecco alcuni esempi di rappresentazioni di Kraus,
partendo dal canale di reset del qubit. Possiamo ottenere una rappresentazione di Kraus per questo canale usando
due matrici di Kraus: |0⟩⟨0| e |0⟩⟨1|. Quindi N è uguale a due in questo esempio.
Possiamo inserire queste scelte nella formula generale e abbiamo solo due termini, quindi è facile scrivere la somma.
E se semplifichiamo e riconosciamo che l'espressione tra parentesi è la traccia di ρ, vediamo che otteniamo
il canale di reset del qubit. Possiamo anche verificare che la condizione richiesta su queste matrici sia soddisfatta, e questo è una semplice questione di inserire le matrici di Kraus
nell'equazione e valutare, e otteniamo la matrice identità come richiesto. Per un altro esempio, guardiamo di nuovo il
canale di defasing completo. Prendere le matrici |0⟩⟨0| e |1⟩⟨1| funziona, e questo può essere verificato espandendo la somma
e vedendo abbastanza direttamente che otteniamo ciò che ci serve. E ancora la condizione richiesta è soddisfatta. Un'
alternativa è prendere A₀ uguale alla matrice identità diviso √2 e A₁ uguale a
Sigma_Z / √2. E se valutiamo vediamo che ancora una volta otteniamo il canale di defasing completo, basandoci sull'osservazione
l'alternativa è prendere A0 uguale alla matrice identità divisa per √2 e A1 uguale a
Sigma Z diviso √2, e se valutiamo vediamo che ancora una volta otteniamo il canale di defasing completo, basandoci sull'osservazione
verificare come esercizio da svolgere se ti fosse utile. Considera il canale completamente depolarizzante,
che restituisce lo stato completamente misto per ogni input come matrice densità. Per questo servono quattro matrici di Kraus:
non è possibile trovare una rappresentazione di Kraus in cui N sia tre o meno. Ecco una scelta che funziona, e
ecco un'altra. Quindi l'esercizio è verificare che queste scelte funzionino e anche verificare che la condizione richiesta
sia soddisfatta. Vale la pena sottolineare che la seconda alternativa dice fondamentalmente che è possibile depolarizzare completamente un qubit, ovvero
randomizzarlo completamente, scegliendo casualmente una delle quattro matrici di Pauli inclusa l'identità e applicando
la corrispondente operazione unitaria al qubit. Quindi il canale completamente depolarizzante è un altro esempio di canale unitario misto.
L'ultima delle tre rappresentazioni di canali che tratteremo è la rappresentazione di Choi. Man-Duen Choi
è un matematico che lavora sulla teoria delle matrici e altri argomenti, e la rappresentazione di Choi porta il suo nome
in suo onore, basata su un articolo davvero elegante che ha pubblicato nel 1975 che in qualche senso lega tutto insieme. La rappresentazione di
Choi di un canale Φ è una singola matrice, convenzionalmente denotata J(Φ), e specificamente se il
sistema di input ha N stati classici e il sistema di output ha M stati classici, allora la rappresentazione di Choi di Φ sarà
una matrice quadrata N*M per N*M. Prima di dirti esattamente come è definita la matrice, vorrei menzionare un paio delle sue
proprietà chiave, che motivano la rappresentazione in un modo che la definizione effettiva potrebbe non fare, almeno in superficie.
Primo, a differenza sia delle rappresentazioni di Stinespring che delle rappresentazioni di Kraus, la rappresentazione di Choi
è una rappresentazione cosiddetta fedele, il che significa che ogni canale ne ha solo una. E questo è abbastanza importante
perché dice che due canali sono uguali se e solo se le loro rappresentazioni di Choi sono uguali. Quindi se hai
due descrizioni diverse di canali, come due rappresentazioni di Stinespring diverse o due rappresentazioni di Kraus diverse, o forse una di
ciascuna, e vuoi sapere se sono in effetti lo stesso canale, puoi semplicemente calcolare la rappresentazione di Choi e
verificare se sono uguali o meno. La seconda proprietà è che ci sono semplici condizioni da verificare sulla rappresentazione di Choi che sono vere se e solo
se abbiamo un canale valido. Quella proprietà non è così speciale: possiamo dire la stessa cosa delle altre due rappresentazioni. Ma è comunque una buona proprietà
da avere, e ne parleremo più in dettaglio a breve. Un'altra cosa da notare sulla rappresentazione di Choi è che anche se stiamo
rappresentando un canale con una matrice, questa matrice non rappresenta direttamente il canale come mappatura lineare. In effetti è
più naturale associare la rappresentazione di Choi alla matrice densità che rappresenta un certo stato
che non pensare alla rappresentazione di Choi come alla descrizione di una mappatura lineare. È però possibile recuperare l'azione del canale dalla sua
rappresentazione di Choi usando una formula abbastanza semplice, ma non è così semplice come la moltiplicazione matriciale ordinaria.
Basta con il preambolo: arriviamo alla definizione effettiva. Supponiamo di avere un canale Φ dal sistema X al sistema Y,
e assumiamo che l'insieme degli stati classici del sistema di input X sia Σ. Non avremo bisogno di riferirci all'insieme degli stati classici del sistema di output, quindi
per la definizione non c'è bisogno di dargli un nome. La rappresentazione di Choi di Φ è allora definita dall'espressione
mostrata qui sullo schermo. Abbiamo una somma che va su tutti gli stati classici A e B per il sistema di input, e stiamo
sommando |A⟩⟨B| tensorizzato con il canale Φ applicato a |A⟩⟨B|. Quindi questa
rappresentazione è definita da una formula, e ci sono un paio di modi diversi di pensare a questa formula. Prima di discuterli, lasciami
menzionare che a volte la rappresentazione di Choi è definita in modo leggermente diverso, in cui l'ordine dei due fattori tensoriali è invertito, ovvero
Φ(|A⟩⟨B|) appare come primo fattore tensoriale invece che come secondo. Ma i due modi diversi di farlo sono
equivalenti a meno di questa semplice simmetria. Ma ciò che significa è che quando si usa questa rappresentazione è una buona
idea chiarire quale ordinamento si sta usando. Questo ordinamento è come si fa in Qiskit, ed è anche migliore per
descrivere la rappresentazione visivamente in termini di matrici a blocchi, quindi questo è quello che useremo. Per essere più precisi sulla descrizione come matrice a blocchi,
se assumiamo che l'insieme degli stati classici Σ consista degli interi da zero fino a N-1
per qualche intero positivo N, possiamo in alternativa scrivere J(Φ) come matrice a blocchi come mostrato qui sullo
schermo. In altre parole, la rappresentazione di Choi di Φ è la matrice che otteniamo valutando Φ su ciascuna delle
matrici di input che hanno esattamente una voce uguale a uno con tutte le altre voci uguali a zero, e poi disponendole
in una matrice in modo abbastanza naturale. Potrebbe non essere chiaro a priori perché vorremmo formare una matrice come questa, ma
risulta essere molto utile. Una cosa da notare è che l'insieme contenente le matrici |A⟩⟨B| mentre
A e B variano su tutti gli interi da 0 a N-1 forma una base per lo spazio di tutte le matrici N per N. Quindi se
hai questa matrice, puoi certamente determinare cosa fa Φ a una matrice N per N arbitraria per linearità,
specificamente prendendo le opportune combinazioni lineari dei blocchi. Quindi la matrice J(Φ) determina effettivamente in modo univoco Φ come
mappatura lineare. Un altro modo per pensare alla rappresentazione di Choi di un canale è che
rappresenta uno stato come matrice densità quando è normalizzata. Specificamente, dividendo per il numero di
stati classici del sistema di input, che continuerò a denotare con N minuscolo, otterremo sempre una
matrice densità, spesso chiamata lo stato di Choi del canale. Ecco come funziona in maggiore dettaglio:
immaginiamo prima di avere due copie identiche del sistema di input e consideriamo il vettore di stato quantistico S
mostrato sullo schermo, che rappresenta un cosiddetto stato massimalmente entangled di questa coppia di sistemi identici. Ad esempio,
se Σ è l'alfabeto binario, questo è uno stato Φ+. Ma possiamo pensare a uno stato definito in modo analogo per
qualsiasi scelta di Σ, e ciò che otteniamo è uno stato altamente entangled, e in effetti è entangled il più possibile
data questa scelta di sistemi. Per ottenere la rappresentazione come matrice densità dello stato moltiplichiamo il vettore di stato per il suo trasposto coniugato come al solito, e
questo è il suo aspetto. E infine, se pensiamo alla rappresentazione di Choi del canale divisa per N, vediamo che è lo stato che
otterremmo se applicassimo il canale Φ al secondo sistema. Ecco come appare sotto forma di figura: abbiamo due copie del sistema X in
questo stato massimalmente entangled S. Il canale Φ viene applicato al secondo sistema, quello in alto nel diagramma, e lo
stato risultante è lo stato di Choi di Φ. Naturalmente normalmente non daremmo lo stesso nome a due sistemi diversi:
è generalmente non utile dare lo stesso nome a due cose diverse. Ma ha senso in questo caso
solo per fare questa connessione con le rappresentazioni di Choi.
Ci sono un paio di implicazioni che possiamo trarre immediatamente da questo modo di
guardare le rappresentazioni di Choi. Una è che, poiché lo stato di Choi è una matrice densità (assumendo che Φ sia un
canale valido), concludiamo che la rappresentazione di Choi di Φ deve essere semidefinita positiva. Ricorda che è
un requisito che poniamo sui canali che trasformino sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità, e questo
è solo un caso speciale di questo. La seconda implicazione è che se prendiamo lo stato di Choi per qualsiasi canale Φ e
poi scartiamo il sistema di output Y, dobbiamo rimanere con lo stato completamente misto sul sistema di input X. Questo
perché applicare un canale a un sistema e poi buttare il sistema risultante nella spazzatura è equivalente a buttare semplicemente il sistema originale nella
spazzatura. E se lo facessimo con il nostro stato massimalmente entangled, la matrice densità con cui rimarremmo sarebbe
la matrice identità divisa per N, ovvero lo stato completamente misto per il sistema X. L'idea in termini più
matematici è che comporre qualsiasi canale con la traccia sul sistema di output deve essere uguale alla traccia sul
sistema di input. Questo perché i canali devono preservare la traccia, per via del fatto che sono mappature lineari che
trasformano sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità. Una volta che abbiamo questa equazione possiamo eliminare il denominatore N
da entrambi i lati per ottenere una condizione leggermente più pulita. In parole, eseguire la traccia parziale sul sistema di output
della rappresentazione di Choi di un canale deve darci la matrice identità sul sistema di input. Quindi in sintesi, le rappresentazioni di
Choi dei canali sono sempre semidefinite positive, e se tracciamo fuori il sistema di output rimaniamo necessariamente
con la matrice identità sul sistema di input. Si scopre che queste non sono solo condizioni necessarie ma
anche sufficienti, nel senso che se Φ è una mappatura lineare arbitraria e queste due condizioni sono entrambe vere,
allora Φ deve essere di fatto un canale valido. E vedremo perché questo è il caso entro la fine della lezione.
Vediamo alcuni esempi, iniziando con il canale di defasing completo. Per calcolare la rappresentazione di Choi è solo questione di
valutare la formula. Il canale di defasing completo lascia |A⟩⟨B| invariato quando A uguale B e altrimenti l'output
è zero. Quindi i termini nella somma che sopravvivono sono quelli in cui A uguale B, e il risultato è espresso sullo
schermo usando la notazione di Dirac. Possiamo anche vederlo come matrice a blocchi: Δ lascia le voci diagonali invariate e azzera le voci fuori dalla
diagonale. Quindi rimaniamo con una matrice con uno nell'angolo in alto a sinistra e in basso a destra, con tutte le altre voci
uguali a zero, e questo è coerente con la prima espressione. Per un altro esempio, consideriamo il canale completamente depolarizzante. Ancora, possiamo iniziare scrivendo la formula, e proprio come nell'esempio precedente non otteniamo nessun contributo alla somma
quando A non è uguale a B, e questa volta quando A uguale B otteniamo lo stato completamente misto. E possiamo semplificarlo per
ottenere 1/2 volte la matrice identità 2x2 tensorizzata con se stessa, che è 1/2 volte la matrice identità 4x4.
Possiamo anche pensarci in termini di matrici a blocchi e naturalmente otteniamo lo stesso risultato. E come
ultimo esempio, consideriamo il canale identità per un singolo qubit. È un caso facile: ecco la formula, e ovviamente
il canale identità non fa assolutamente nulla. E possiamo pensare al risultato come a due volte la matrice densità associata a uno stato Φ+, e questo
è coerente con quello che ci aspettiamo pensando allo stato di Choi di questo canale. Ed eccolo come matrice a blocchi. Nota in particolare che la rappresentazione di
Choi del canale identità non è la matrice identità: è questa matrice. Abbiamo ora visto tre modi diversi
di rappresentare i canali in termini matematici, cioè le rappresentazioni di Stinespring, le rappresentazioni di Kraus e le rappresentazioni di Choi.
Abbiamo anche la definizione di un canale, ovvero che un canale è una mappatura lineare che trasforma sempre
le matrici densità in matrici densità anche quando il canale viene applicato a solo una parte di un sistema composto. Una domanda molto naturale e molto importante
da porre a questo punto è come sappiamo che queste cose sono tutte equivalenti. Ad esempio, come sappiamo che ogni
mappatura descritta da una qualsiasi di queste rappresentazioni è di fatto un canale valido? E come sappiamo che non stiamo tralasciando nessun canale? Il
resto della lezione descrive come tutto questo può essere ragionato matematicamente. Se sei disposto ad accettare l'equivalenza di queste cose e non ti interessa come può essere
ragionato, allora sei libero di saltare il resto del video. Ma personalmente penso che l'argomentazione sia abbastanza
elegante, ed è un buon esempio di un particolare stile di dimostrazione matematica che compare di tanto in tanto nella teoria dell'informazione quantistica. Non spiegherò
tutti i dettagli: alcuni li lascerò a te, oppure puoi trovarli nel contenuto scritto di questa lezione dove tutto è scritto in
dettaglio. Ma spero di presentare un'immagine ragionevolmente chiara di come funziona tutto. Quello che vogliamo fare è dimostrare
l'equivalenza di una raccolta di affermazioni, e il modo in cui possiamo farlo è impostare un ciclo di implicazioni. In particolare, inizieremo
con la definizione di un canale, ovvero una mappatura lineare che trasforma sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità.
Da questa definizione possiamo ragionare che la rappresentazione di Choi di questo canale deve soddisfare le due condizioni che
abbiamo già identificato. E in effetti lo abbiamo già fatto: questo è stato discusso nel contesto dello stato di Choi di un canale. Poi
dimentichiamo tutto della definizione e lavoriamo dalla rappresentazione di Choi, e date le nostre due condizioni sulle rappresentazioni di Choi concludiamo
che deve esistere una rappresentazione di Kraus della mappatura Φ. Poi facciamo un'analoga cosa: dimentichiamo le rappresentazioni di Choi e lavoriamo
da una rappresentazione di Kraus arbitraria, e da essa possiamo ragionare che deve esistere una rappresentazione di Stinespring per la mappatura Φ. E tra l'altro queste
argomentazioni saranno meccaniche in un certo senso, il che ci permette di eseguire effettivamente le conversioni secondo le frecce per canali specifici se vogliamo
farlo. L'ultima implicazione è ragionare che se abbiamo una rappresentazione di Stinespring per una mappatura Φ allora
quella mappatura deve essere di fatto un canale valido. E ancora una volta lo abbiamo già fatto, questa volta nel contesto delle rappresentazioni di Stinespring.
Nel complesso, queste quattro implicazioni rivelano che queste quattro cose sono tutte equivalenti, perché puoi partire da qualsiasi di esse e
seguire le implicazioni transitivamente per arrivare a qualsiasi delle altre. Inizieremo con la prima implicazione,
ovvero che se abbiamo un canale Φ, cioè una mappa lineare che trasforma sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità, allora ha una rappresentazione di Choi
che soddisfa le due condizioni che abbiamo identificato in precedenza, cioè che sia semidefinita positiva
e che se tracciamo fuori il sistema di output otteniamo l'identità sul sistema di input. E come ho menzionato un momento fa, abbiamo
già trattato questa implicazione nel contesto degli stati di Choi. In particolare, quando dividiamo la rappresentazione di Choi di un canale per N, il numero di
stati classici del sistema di input, otteniamo una matrice densità. E inoltre lo stato ridotto del sistema di input
X per quello stato è lo stato completamente misto, ovvero la matrice identità divisa per N. Eliminando il denominatore otteniamo le nostre
due condizioni. Quindi questa implicazione è abbastanza rapida e facile, perché l'abbiamo già trattata.
Ora esaminiamo la seconda implicazione. Questa volta iniziamo con la rappresentazione di Choi di una mappatura che
assumiamo soddisfi i due requisiti, e il nostro obiettivo è trovare una rappresentazione di Kraus per questa mappatura che
soddisfi il requisito di cui abbiamo parlato prima. Questa implicazione è abbastanza meccanica in un certo senso: avremo bisogno di
un po' di algebra lineare e si ridurrà principalmente alla manipolazione di matrici e vettori in modo abbastanza intelligente.
Inizia con l'ipotesi che la rappresentazione di Choi sia semidefinita positiva, che è il primo dei due requisiti che
assumiamo siano in atto. La nozione di matrice semidefinita positiva è fondamentalmente importante nell'informazione quantistica, e non solo nel contesto delle matrici
densità. È assolutamente critica qui: non potremmo fare funzionare questo senza di essa. In particolare, l'ipotesi
che J(Φ) sia semidefinita positiva ci permette di esprimerla nella forma mostrata sullo schermo, per qualche scelta di
vettori S₀ fino a S_ e per qualche scelta di un intero positivo N. Notiamo esplicitamente che questi non sono
necessariamente vettori unitari. Un modo per ottenere un'espressione come questa è dal teorema spettrale per le matrici semidefinite
positive, di cui abbiamo parlato nella lezione precedente. Qui non vediamo comparire esplicitamente autovalori come avremmo in una decomposizione
spettrale, ma ricorda che gli autovalori delle matrici semidefinite positive sono sempre numeri reali non negativi, e tieni presente che non stiamo
richiedendo che questi vettori S₀ fino a S_ siano vettori unitari. Quindi quello che possiamo fare è prendere le radici quadrate degli
autovalori e moltiplicarle per i vettori unitari degli autovettori che otteniamo da una decomposizione spettrale per ottenere questi
vettori S₀ fino a S_. Non è effettivamente importante per questa dimostrazione che questi vettori siano ortogonali: lo otteniamo
da una decomposizione spettrale, ma non lo useremo qui. E se avessimo qualche espressione diversa di J(Φ) come questa che non proviene dal teorema
spettrale, andrebbe ugualmente bene. Ora decomponiamo ciascuno di questi vettori come mostrato sullo schermo, e
questo è proprio come faremmo se questi vettori fossero vettori di stato quantistici di una coppia di sistemi XY e stessimo
eseguendo una misurazione nella base standard sul sistema X. Per chiarire, non stiamo misurando nulla qui: stiamo solo scrivendo questi vettori in questa forma, che
è sempre possibile. E ora arriva il trucco: definiamo le matrici di Kraus A₀ fino a A_ estraendo i
|A⟩ dalla parte anteriore di questi vettori S₀ fino a S_, capovolgendoli in modo che diventino ⟨A| invece di |A⟩,
e mettendoli a destra come mostrato nell'equazione sullo schermo. Un modo per pensarci
è che stiamo fondamentalmente piegando questi vettori per formare matrici, in modo che se impilassimo le colonne di A_K una sull'altra otterremmo
di nuovo S_K. Quindi queste matrici hanno esattamente le stesse voci dei vettori corrispondenti, ma abbiamo solo
riorganizzato le voci in modo diverso per ottenere matrici. Ma possiamo anche pensare a queste matrici puramente simbolicamente in termini di notazione di Dirac
come scritto qui. E ora a questo punto c'è una domanda ovvia: perché dovrebbe funzionare? Ebbene, non soffermiamoci troppo su
perché funziona: verifichiamo semplicemente che lo fa. Per farlo, definiamo una nuova mappatura che è la mappatura definita
da queste matrici trattandole come matrici di Kraus. Quello che possiamo fare ora è calcolare la rappresentazione di Choi di
questa nuova mappatura e vedremo che è uguale alla rappresentazione di Choi della mappatura Φ con cui abbiamo iniziato. E
poiché le rappresentazioni di Choi sono fedeli, ciò significa che le due mappature sono in effetti uguali. Non spiegherò l'algebra in questo video:
puoi verificarla tu stesso. È abbastanza meccanica ed è un buon esercizio, e tutto ciò di cui hai bisogno per farlo è proprio
qui sullo schermo. Non abbiamo ancora detto nulla sulla seconda condizione nelle due caselle, ma
si scopre che sono equivalenti. Un modo per stabilirlo è verificare l'equazione mostrata qui in basso sullo
schermo. La lettera T qui, tra l'altro, si riferisce alla trasposizione della matrice, che puoi in alternativa pensare come la
mappatura lineare che trasforma |A⟩⟨B| in |B⟩⟨A|. Ed è solo qualcosa che serve per far funzionare la formula. Quindi in
sintesi, c'è sicuramente un po' di algebra necessaria per questa implicazione, ma come ho detto è tutta abbastanza meccanica:
la "ginnastica degli indici" come alcune persone la chiamano. Ma se la elabori e dai al tuo cervello la possibilità di digerirla, potresti trovare che esci con una
migliore comprensione di come le rappresentazioni di Choi e le rappresentazioni di Kraus si relazionano. La terza implicazione ci permette di
passare da una rappresentazione di Kraus di una mappatura Φ, in cui la solita condizione è in atto, a una rappresentazione di Stinespring. Questa è abbastanza
simile in spirito all'implicazione precedente nel senso che è meccanica e può essere vista e verificata in termini puramente algebrici. L'
idea è in realtà abbastanza semplice: quello che possiamo fare è prendere le nostre matrici di Kraus e formare parte di una matrice più grande impilando
su di esse come mostrato sullo schermo. Una volta completata questa sarà la matrice unitaria U per una
rappresentazione di Stinespring. Le matrici unitarie devono essere matrici quadrate, quindi dovremo riempire tutte le colonne rimanenti
di cui abbiamo bisogno per farlo. Ma non farà alcuna differenza cosa sono, purché otteniamo una matrice unitaria.
Se mettiamo momentaneamente da parte la preoccupazione che U sia unitaria e ci concentriamo solo sulla mappatura lineare definita dalla
rappresentazione di Stinespring che otteniamo da questa matrice U, allora quello che troviamo è che la mappatura è uguale alla
mappatura Φ originale definita dalla rappresentazione di Kraus con cui abbiamo iniziato. Questa è un'altra parte della dimostrazione che non spiegherò in questo video: puoi
trovare i dettagli nel contenuto scritto di questa lezione, ma potresti in alternativa voler dedicare un po' di tempo a lavorarci tu stesso. Tieni solo
presente come al solito per la serie che stiamo usando la convenzione di ordinamento dei ket per interpretare il diagramma, quindi W e G corrisponderanno
ai fattori tensoriali sul lato sinistro nelle equazioni. E tra l'altro, se lo fai
troverai che poiché abbiamo |0⟩⟨0| come fattore tensoriale sul lato sinistro nell'equazione
che dobbiamo verificare, l'unica porzione di U che ha rilevanza è la parte fornita dalle matrici di Kraus. Quindi finché riempiamo
le colonne di U in modo da renderla unitaria, siamo a posto. Ma naturalmente questo richiede che le colonne formate da A₀ fino a A_
quando le impiliamo una sull'altra siano ortonormali, ed è qui che entra in gioco la condizione che poniamo sulle rappresentazioni di Kraus.
E in effetti è precisamente equivalente alle colonne che sono ortonormali. Le relazioni matematiche rilevanti necessarie per trarre questa
conclusione sono mostrate in basso sullo schermo. Quindi vai avanti e verifica se vuoi, oppure
consulta il contenuto scritto per ulteriori dettagli. In breve, quello che sta succedendo sia in questa implicazione che in quella
precedente è che stiamo descrivendo le stesse operazioni matematiche in modi diversi ma equivalenti. Il
cuore pulsante di tutto questo è essenzialmente la moltiplicazione matriciale. La quarta e ultima implicazione stabilisce che se abbiamo
una rappresentazione di Stinespring per una qualche mappatura, allora quella mappatura deve essere di fatto un canale valido. E come ho indicato
prima, abbiamo già trattato questa implicazione quando abbiamo discusso le rappresentazioni di Stinespring. In sintesi, e in
termini leggermente diversi:
introdurre un sistema workspace inizializzato è un canale valido. Questo perché tensorizzare una matrice densità fissa a una data matrice densità dà sempre una matrice densità, ed è una mappatura lineare per la bilinearità
dei prodotti tensoriali. Le operazioni unitarie sono sempre canali validi, come ho discusso prima nella lezione. Tracciare fuori un sistema è un canale valido perché la
traccia parziale è una mappatura lineare che trasforma sempre le matrici densità in matrici densità. E infine, le composizioni di
canali sono sempre canali, il che è abbastanza semplice ma vale sicuramente la pena osservarlo di per sé. E con le
quattro implicazioni che abbiamo appena trattato, abbiamo stabilito l'equivalenza delle nostre tre rappresentazioni di canali insieme alla
definizione originale di un canale. In particolare, siamo partiti dalla definizione di un canale, abbiamo visto come quella definizione implica che la sua rappresentazione di Choi
soddisfa necessariamente due condizioni di base. Poi abbiamo visto come quelle condizioni ci permettono di trovare una rappresentazione di Kraus, che a sua volta
ci permette di trovare una rappresentazione di Stinespring. E infine abbiamo visto che l'esistenza di una rappresentazione di Stinespring rivela che abbiamo
in effetti un canale valido. Naturalmente ci sono dettagli tecnici in mezzo, e non è necessariamente semplice, specialmente
quando la vedi per la prima volta. Ma ciò che è interessante e degno di nota è che queste implicazioni sono impostate in un modo che in effetti rende
le cose il più facili possibile. E in matematica non dovresti mai vergognarti di prendere la via più facile.
Ad esempio, non è affatto ovvio che ogni canale abbia una rappresentazione di Stinespring o di Kraus,
ma è relativamente facile concludere che la rappresentazione di Choi di ogni canale soddisfa le due condizioni che le abbiamo associate. E questo
ci permette di seguire un percorso più o meno algebrico verso le altre due rappresentazioni. In modo simile, l'ultima
implicazione da una rappresentazione di Stinespring alla definizione è anche relativamente semplice, e ci
permette di concludere che otteniamo solo canali e nessun'altra mappatura dalle rappresentazioni di Choi, assumendo che le
condizioni richieste siano soddisfatte. E come ho accennato prima, il modo in cui argomentiamo queste implicazioni è sufficientemente meccanico da permetterci di
convertire facilmente tra le rappresentazioni. E se torni ad alcuni degli esempi che abbiamo trattato prima nella lezione, troverai che è in effetti possibile
convertire tra le rappresentazioni, a volte abbastanza facilmente e direttamente. Ed è questo che conclude la
lezione, che è stata tutta sui canali. Abbiamo parlato di cosa sono e abbiamo dato uno sguardo ad alcuni esempi di base. Abbiamo discusso tre modi in cui i canali possono
essere rappresentati, e ci siamo immersi in alcuni dettagli tecnici che stabiliscono l'equivalenza di queste rappresentazioni.
Spero che ti unirai a me per la prossima lezione, che riguarda tutta le misurazioni nella formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica.
Arrivederci.